the airfield at Benoit is located 25
kilometers northeast of Saigon army
aviation crews here are busy servicing a
uh-1b helicopter gunship they are
getting it ready for another combat
assault mission and the checklist is
thorough now late in April the daily
duties of aircraft crews include
maintenance and rearming here 2.75
Rockets are loaded into the gunship pods
some choppers carry as many as 24
rockets
while the airlifting of troops and
matériel remains the prime function of
the chopper in Vietnam the armed
helicopter is affording assault
commanders a support weapon ideally
suited to warfare in the jungles swamps
and brushy countryside of Southeast Asia
these gunships originally armed with
small bore automatic weapons are today
little short of flying Arsenal's in
recent weeks some of these combat ships
have been augmented with 20 millimeter
cannon greatly increasing the firepower
of these choppers m60 machine guns on
flexible mounts are standard along with
the smaller m16 from their vantage point
overlooking enemy positions in the
undergrowth below the pilots can lay
down suppressing fire with maximum
effect unlike fixed-wing aircraft the
choppers offer complete maneuverability
in the immediate target area gunships of
this aviation battalion have flown more
than 4,000 sorties during the month of
April hitting the Vietcong where he
lives since the first of January 1965
the aviation battalion flying out of
Benoit has received two distinguished
service crosses 15 Silver Stars and a
host of other decorations at a forward
landing zone outside of khushi 24
kilometres northwest of Saigon us
infantry troops received delivery of
ammunition and food as the helicopters
carry out a different kind of mission
the resupply choppers bring in their
cargos and unloading begins at once
discharge and pick up is accomplished in
minutes and the Huey's soar away toward
their home base one of the most unusual
missions perform by the army aviation
helicopters is seagoing duty in support
of u.s. naval operations along the
rivers and waterways of South Vietnam
aboard the USS Tortuga somewhere in the
South China Sea flight deck takeoffs and
landings are practiced by the army
flyers operating from the converted LSD
26 while it is underway requires some
getting used to this unit of army
helicopters calling itself the Seawolves
flies security cover for the naval
patrol boats as they run up the coastal
rivers the thousands of miles of Delta
land waterways are systematically combed
to prevent the Vietnamese communists
from moving men and supplies by both for
now the flying is finished for the day
tomorrow these gunships will shuttle
back and forth along the coast hunting
Vietcong targets of opportunity in all
it is the most unusual experience for
these army flyers
on 9 April a c-130 lands at we've our
air strip to help airlift a battalion of
the one hundred and first airborne from
Thuy vu north of Cam Ranh Bay all of the
units personnel and equipment will be
flown to font yet to take part in
operation Austin later passing over the
font yet staging area the c-130
completes the 280 kilometers flight to
the adjacent font yet Army Airfield here
the paratroopers debark with their
personal equipment followed by a two and
one half ton truck the airlift continues
as the Chinook delivers additional
troops and equipment font yet on the
coast due east of Saigon will serve as
the base for this Search and Destroy
operation the build-up of the battalion
base continues as another Chinook
delivers a sling loaded lightweight m102
howitzer which is quickly prepared for
firing on 12 April operation Austin
kicks off with an airstrike on suspected
bc areas near font yet on both sides of
the border between Dean tuan and Binh
Thuy provinces by 13 April the
paratroopers are well along on their
Search and Destroy operation finding
some unfinished bamboo structures they
decide the VC were interrupted while
constructing a rest camp and tear it
down this platoon will make no other
contact for five days however near the
battalion CP on 15 April a 4.2 inch
mortar crew is called on to support
another reconnaissance platoon under
attack
on 19 April the paratroopers capture and
interrogate to vc one of whom has been
wounded by 21 April operation Austin
Nets a total of twenty-five DC killed
and 21 suspects question this particular
interrogation causes them to modify
their roots as the operation continues
the airstrip at on K is the scene of
havoc caused by communist terrorists the
office housing the passenger booking
service is a shambles as the result of
explosives concealed under the desk and
set off during the night of 20 april
this c-130 aircraft was also damaged by
the infiltrating terrorists who
penetrated the air base defenses
undetected in the darkness the enemy
planted several explosive charges one of
the hidden devices blew the bottom out
of this aircraft in addition other areas
of the base were also damaged in another
attack upon an airfield two days later
the Vietcong launched a surprise mortar
attack against the play KU airbase 72
kilometers west of anche in this
incident several Airmen were killed
while on guard duty the Vietcong struck
at oh 200 hours and the mortar shelling
completely destroyed two aircraft and
damaged a number of others all aircraft
were parked in revet ments at the time
of the attack in the broad light of day
the full extent of the damage is
determined and the work of salvaging and
repairing begun
the main base of the 1st Cavalry
Division airmobile is situated at on K
in the central highlands of South
Vietnam on the twenty-seventh of April
major-general Harry wo Cunard then
commanding the division described the
air mobility concept and the operations
of the division our concept of
operations when we arrived here was
first of all to make this base at on
cave a very hard very compact base which
could be easily defended by the minimum
number of troops all to the end that the
maximum number of our forces could be
used externally as a fire brigade in
fact the analogy of the firehouse is not
a bad one Conte our base is the
firehouse but we don't fight the fires
here we go out to find the fires and to
stamp them out and we have been doing
just that ever since beginning on the
18th to sep tember with our first combat
operation and this one by the way when
approximately half of the division was
still on the high seas in this combat in
which we've engaged since last
September's we found to our great
satisfaction that the technique de
tactic the equipment that was developed
during the 11th Air Assault days and
since then has proven itself extremely
well in actual combat with a real enemy
our aerial cavalry has been able to find
the enemy our aerial engineers moving by
helicopter have been able to move to the
most inaccessible places and bill
landing zones for our helicopters and
even landing strips for fixed-wing
aircraft as large as c-130 our tube
artillery has been able to move and our
large Chinook helicopters into
inaccessible areas completely devoid of
road
and to set up there and provide support
for our infantryman so that when the VC
fire at our infantry with their rifles
the response which they receive from us
is with a volley of 105 millimeter
artillery our aerial rocket helicopters
gorillas we have fought the main force
units of the VC and we have thought
regiments and in fact whole divisions of
the North Vietnamese Army unit we have
found that uniformly we are able to
fight these people not on their terms
but on our terms because of our
increased mobility and that we are able
to overcome them we feel that we have
been very successful and we expect to be
more so as we continue to involve to
evolve our tactics and techniques and
learn more about this country its
weather and the enemy
on 28 April a Vietnamese civilian plane
taking off at the con tomb Airport
crash-landed at the end of the airstrip
killing three people and injuring a
number of persons living near the field
u.s. army personnel of this 1st air
cavalry division forward area aid the
pilot and other victims a u.s. sergeant
brings an unconscious girl to medical
aid here medics note her heart has
stopped and hurried to the treatment 10
another victim is x-rayed by field
equipment the pilot is brought to the
medical unit extreme emergency treatment
including pure oxygen is given the
lifeless child the distressed father of
the girl is comforted by an American
sergeant physical stimulation of the
heart and other treatment continue for
half an hour before heart action is
restored her condition remained critical
a practice Hospital atomic alert is held
23 to 25 April by the 46th surgical
hospital located at lunch total Germany
it is decided that the hazard is too
great to proceed the members of the
convoy are ordered to take cover in
tunnels which are located along the
route of the convoy in its part of the
exercise the eighth evacuation hospital
must cross the Rhine they work in
conjunction with a West German army
pioneer company personnel and vehicles
are moved aboard German river barges the
500 17th medical company is transported
by train mess facilities are provided
for all personnel this hospital train is
part of the emergency plan trucks are
coordinated with the trains planned
arrival to transport the personnel and
equipment to their destination medical
supplies and technical apparatus are
moved in protective field cases as
quickly as possible the trucks move off
again
at the appointed destination facilities
are reestablished in this location
judged to be a safe area hospital
facilities designated wagonmaster or
soon operational the boxes and cases of
supplies are brought in the transfer of
patients to the tent hospital is
practiced by the stretcher bearers
throughout the move records are kept and
checks are made of radiation soldiers
practice sweeping radioactive dust from
vehicles a complex and critical move of
vital facilities is successfully
accomplished in this demanding exercise
this helicopter is flying on an errand
the fengo the date is April 26 at
sanchez friends have scored an elderly
lady in ill health to the waiting
helicopter she will be carried in flight
on a stretcher if the woman were to take
the customary long trip over the rough
roads to santa domingo her illness would
become fatal according to local medical
authorities inside the helicopter she is
taken care of by her daughter and son
this is the third medical evacuation
flown by us helicopters to the capital
today the helicopter arrives at its
destination the patient will be taken to
the Dominican Red Cross Hospital in
Santo Domingo the capital city with its
nearly 400,000 in population offers for
better medical facilities than normally
would be available to the Dominican
countryside this on improved road leads
to the town of dececco in the Dominican
Republic the main paved highway runs
within seven miles of the town but the
dirt road to deseo itself is impossible
to motor vehicles the US Army is lending
to bulldozers and a road grader to help
the privately financed International
Development Foundation improved the road
on 18 April the men and equipment enter
the old road to begin work the vehicles
and trailers negotiate the narrow town
streets with difficulty to live the
people must get their produce to market
at present they have to carry it on
their backs or by animal to the main
road
yucca corn beans and tobacco are their
main products here women string Tibet
600 families of the cycle expanding
trade will bring improved living
conditions
u.s. army engineers or helping Bolivia
rebuild vital roads in the rugged
mountainous terrain where the tin mines
which are the backbone of that country's
economy are located in 1964 10
constituted 75% of the 108 million
dollars in mineral exports all other
exports totaled only six million this
50-year old mine photographed in april
may run out in five to six years idling
thousands already government operated
mines have lowered employment from
32,000 to 23,000 the main hope of
economic survival is for private
industry to locate and develop new mines
to counter the loss of jobs and revenue
there is no problem in transporting or
to the surface the serious problem for
further private development lies in
getting the product to export points
many of the roads are steep narrow and
winding muddy river for dings cause
slippery break bands wild animals
frequent the road the lack of edge
perfection has cost hundreds of lives in
truck accidents
at the bolivian rio colorado camp a u.s.
army engineer consults with a bolivian
engineer on the worst stretch of road
which runs through the heart of the
mining region so narrow that it daily
alternates one-way traffic this road has
no this year a 450 thousand dollar US
aid grant has been made for the project
along the critical 250 kilometers
stretch repairs expansion and other
improvements are underway eroded places
in the road are restored coverts to
prevent further erosion at established
drainage points will conduct water
safely under the road the US captain
distributes to the laborers cartoon
comic style booklets which present our
point of view the Bolivian national road
service heads the overall project in
which the government mining office
bolivian military and US aid worked
together
young Dominican leftists race their
motorbike engines to the beat of the
familiar chant go home Yankee it is 28
April in Santo Domingo and the first
anniversary of US military intervention
here members of the 82nd airborne
prepare for a long day and possible
trouble they are stationed out of sight
behind the u.s. embassy residence ready
for action as reinforcements to the
National Police if there is any attempt
to raid the American Embassy riot
control maps are checked as a precaution
several thousand students gather outside
the American Embassy to protest the
streets throughout the capital are
guarded by hundreds of Dominican
policemen armed with automatic weapons
and carrying gas masks tight security
precautions reflect the tension during
this week of ceremonies marking the
overthrow of the Cabral regime in April
1965
there is no violence but as at most
Dominican leftist rallies u.s. flags are
burned
on the first of May the National
Memorial Cemetery of the Pacific is
dedicated in Honolulu Hawaii located in
the pool winer crater an extinct volcano
overlooking the city of Honolulu the 112
acre cemetery is the last of 18 national
memorials to be dedicated to the dead of
World War two and Korea Admiral us G
sharp commander in chief Pacific heads
the list of dignitaries to inspect the
honor guard post for the ceremonies is
the American battle monuments Commission
in the audience of more than 5,000 our
congressional representatives veterans
groups American War mothers official
state groups and civic groups the honor
guard is composed of military personnel
selected from each of the nation's armed
services beginning the ceremonies is
retired general jakob L Devers chairman
of the battle monuments Commission
there's a great privilege and a great
honor to welcome you to this ceremony of
dedication of a national memorial this
is the last to be completed of the 18
memorials erected by the American battle
monuments Commission in tribute to the
sacrifices and to honor the achievements
of its men and women of the armed forces
during world war two and in Korea then
the Honorable John a burns governor of
the state of Hawaii we are most highly
honored the Hawaii was selected as the
site for one of our most historical
shrines the National Memorial Cemetery
of the Pacific we fully appreciate the
high privilege of providing the last
resting place for America's brave men
and women who gave their lives for our
nation the principal speaker of the day
is Admiral us G sharp commander of US
forces in the Pacific today we are
gathered here to honor these Americans
who are missing from the campaign
in the Pacific during World War two and
the Korean conflict the attack on Pearl
Harbor sparked the conflict which flamed
and spread throughout the Pacific Midway
Guadalcanal Tarawa Saipan lady Iwo Jima
Okinawa and finally Tokyo Bay less than
five years after the final shot was
fired in World War two communist
aggression broke out in Korea twice in
less than a decade Americans were called
upon to make the ultimate sacrifice in
the cause of freedom in dedicating this
monument to the memory of missing
American heroes we should commit
ourselves to continuing the task they
struggle to advance to realize for our
generation on this earth a continuous
rebirth of freedom the true revolution
for the rights of men and the rule of
law and peace in the spirit of this
commitment and in the name of the people
of the United States of America I
declare this memorial to be dedicated in
proud remembrance of the achievements of
these heroic men and women and in humble
tribute to their sacrifice
now comes the most solemn moment of the
occasion as the combined US Army and
Marine bands play the historic him abide
with me Admiral sharp places the wreath
of the President of the United States at
the monument of the missing this is the
first of many floral tributes presented
this day
at the conclusion of the formal
ceremonies the new national memorial is
inspected by the public overlooking the
monumental stairway is a 30-foot figure
of Columbia flanked by eight memorial
courts of the missing bus a grateful
country pays homage to its honored dead
of World War two and Korea